on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
tonight appears morgan uncensored sealed
by the royal hand now prime minister
trust shakes up the british government
but how will she pay for her big energy
bailout
as crime hits a 20-year high of police
lost control of broken britain
fast trafficking victim or playing the
victim should we show mercy to isis
bride shamima begum and allow her back
to the uk
[Music]
live from london this
is morgan uncensored
well good evening welcome to piers
morgan uncensored my little rant last
night about the state of broken britain
has had about 2 million views so far
across various platforms suggesting it
hit a nerve with you the viewers and i'm
not surprised because we're all feeling
aren't we that this country is careering
out of control and the person who's been
charged with putting it back on the
rails
is liz trust well nothing will be
straightforward the new prime minister
she's britain's fourth pm in six years
and she steps directly into a cost of
living crisis an energy crisis a health
crisis a crime crisis a migrant crisis
even a sewage in the sea crisis it's a
crisis of crises
and they say don't they that you need to
be a lucky general well she couldn't
have started worse really first of all
it rained on her parade quite literally
just rained rained and rained after
boris this morning sailed off in bright
sunshine and then when she went up to
scotland this trust to meet the queen
have it all formalized well she got
stuck in the air wasn't able to land for
quite a while
that's not a good start for any general
is it a lot of rain and stuck in the air
i hope things improve for this trust
because honestly i want her to succeed
anyway the queen ratified this uh from
balmoral uh this trust is the new prime
minister and tonight she's got this
burgeoning in tray of problems to deal
with
well uh
she addressed the nation i was going to
bring you the best bits of it but
actually we were going through a little
earlier we decided there weren't many in
fact this was probably the most
memorable thing she said
thank you
[Applause]
thank you well i'm sure she's very
grateful for the job
i'll be grateful if she keeps her
promise and fixes the problems that we
have the speech was light on detail in
fact there wasn't a detail in the speech
and that is worrying i think but trust
did say she'll unveil help on the
rocketing cost of energy later this week
reports suggesting she's preparing a
bailout of up to 100 billion pounds to
keep families and businesses afloat
bills could be capped reportedly at two
and a half thousand pounds but how she's
going to pay for this remains unclear
particularly given her commitment to
actually cut taxes
and who she's going to rely on to help
navigate the storm whilst becoming a
little clearer tonight her first cabinet
appointments include her close friend
and ally teresa coffey as health
secretary and deputy prime minister
sweeley bravoman is a new home secretary
james cleverley becomes foreign
secretary quasi quatting will be the
chancellor basically everybody who
didn't suck up to lose trust has been
shoved out the door which is what tends
to happen in these things let's get into
all this with my uh gloriously exotic
peers back tonight i'm joined by tall tv
presenter richard theis political
commentator grace blakely best-selling
author douglas murray new york post
columnist maureen callan and talk tv
political editor kate mccann but welcome
to all of you okay let me start with you
uh a busy busy busy night going on down
there in westminster not really that
surprising everybody who didn't support
this trust fired unceremoniously and all
the suck-ups get all the top jobs
well that's certainly one way of putting
it and it is what we are starting to see
in those early big appointments those
people who've been closest to list trust
throughout this campaign to raise coffee
as you said
top job deputy prime minister and health
secretary a really significant part of
the three-point plan plan that liz trust
announced today in downing street and
others too quasi qatang now he is going
to have one of the most difficult jobs
in government i think of well any of the
last couple of governments because he's
going to have to tackle the energy
crisis he's going to potentially have to
announce as you said there 100 billion
plus plan to solve the energy bill
problem that list trust is now faced
with and that it sounds like could go on
borrowing just essentially topping up
what is already a significant debt pile
that the uk government is sitting on now
some in list trusses inner circle are
not particularly worried about that they
think that the uk economy can grow and
that ultimately things will be fine but
there are others who are a little bit
more worried and concerned still that it
might not be enough and ultimately list
trust may have to go further if as we
expect this plan will potentially run
out sometime around christmas next year
so an unenviable task but as you say so
far a cabinet stuff would loyalist
perhaps not surprising but there will be
those in westminster and some of them
were wandering the corridors with their
phones just held out in front of them
just you know looking for a bit of phone
signal who want to be in those top jobs
who will be missing out because they
didn't back the right candidate it'll be
fascinating to see what happens to penny
morden she's been tweeting very
supportively of lystros in the last
couple of hours maybe she might be in
line for a top job too oh they'll be
they'll be greasing away weren't they on
social media oh she's wonderful
wonderful please give me a job um my
problem is i couldn't get past the rosie
coffee as deputy prime minister and
health secretary but apart from the
house she's not exactly a picture of
health issue i don't mean to be personal
but she's a she's a big smoker she's
clearly overweight is she the right
person to be lecturing us all on public
health
well look i think teresa's coffee is
handled one of the most difficult briefs
in government the dwp department for
work and pensions and what she's done is
quietly navigate her way through some
pretty big challenges and got what she
wanted you may not know to raise coffee
people may not recognize that name and
immediately know what she looks like but
she has made a difference in a
department which usually is regarded as
impossible to run she thought could she
soon act
universal credit uplift i know look i i
i'm sure you're right but i've
interviewed her several times and i
thought she was shockingly mediocre the
only thing i remember for actually where
i thought she had a tick in the credit
boxes was her performance at a karaoke
let's take a look at this
[Music]
that is our new deputy prime minister
great to move on i think from partygate
to
that
well look i'm sure piers morgan that you
wouldn't get angry with people for
having a little bit of fun
but i mean look there are questions
about liz truss's cabinet they are
largely though questions of experience
people saying well you've put some
people in top jobs who haven't
necessarily held them before i think
there's coffee has proved that she has
the metal she may not be what you expect
in terms of a minister in a top position
in government but she certainly made her
way in a difficult department as i said
and she's been so close to liz trust in
this campaign she's one of her key
allies she will also be as i said deputy
prime minister and that's a job that
requires someone with an even
temperament somebody who isn't going to
rock the boat and crucially somebody who
isn't in it for themselves this trust is
surrounding herself with people who she
trusts who she doesn't think are going
to come for her when her back is turned
and after the last couple of years in
downing street seeing what's happened to
conservative prime ministers i mean i
think that's probably something she's
going to value above everything else all
right uh k mccann what are nine eights
what a nine eight nine times eight
oh no don't hit me with math questions
masters i am so bad at fantastic you
don't actually know what
there's a reason i'm asking you i'll
take you off the hook because actually i
did ask our new prime minister that very
question on good morning britain and
watch watch the terrified face a bit
like yours and the pause that happened
watch this
like mine yeah what's this uh nine times
eight
uh
nine times eight is 72 but i'm not going
to answer any more of these questions
piers i knew you were going to ask me
that you know what i think one of the
problems we've got
people get put on the spot
she was literally on that day to talk
about maths right i didn't think
so i'm not going to answer any more of
your questions piers about the thing
i've come on to talk about anyway it's
quite clear uh mr mccann that you know
as little about math as the prime
minister which is a little unsettling to
discover because i thought you knew
everything uh but uh kate it's gonna be
a lot going on you better get back to
your workstation if we get if we get any
more dramatic developments uh let us
know otherwise we'll see you again
tomorrow take care
[Music]
we're not going to do carry over i
wouldn't mind doing karaoke
um let's come to our our peers pack uh
grace blakely i haven't seen you for a
while hey nice to be back welcome back
nice of you to stop gallivanting around
the world um what do you make of all
this
well i mean you know i think what we've
just heard the uh trust has appointed a
lot of key allies to um senior positions
uh out of basically fear that she's to
be stabbed in the back tells you a lot
of what you need to know about this
government which is that she's come in
from a relatively weak position she
doesn't have the support of a lot of her
mps she doesn't have as strong support
among the conservative party membership
as we might have thought certainly at
the beginning of the campaign the
campaign obviously had its own fair
share of fiascos and u-turns um and
didn't leave her
looking particularly prime ministerial
and now she's going into this massive
crisis you know and she has to basically
try and unite two wings of the
conservative party one of which is kind
of boris's populist um you know what
yeah
and then the the right wing free market
near liberal here's the problem richard
said i don't care about the infighting
of the bloody conservative party i want
them to focus on the people of this
country it all revolves that's my
problem i'm fed up with all this in
fighting and to be honest piers it all
revolves around the energy plan i
produced a a an emergency energy plan
three weeks ago i know it's been looked
at in the heart of government if she
gets that right
this week she will get a big big boost
she will unite millions of households up
and down the country how can she do it
and
cut taxes very simply you put the you
put the onus on the uh the gas producers
the energy generators not on us the
taxpayer and the borrower because
otherwise you're literally borrowing
from us taxpayer to give it to your
producers i said you've got to revert to
the average 2021 price for the wholesale
price and you've got to say to all the
generators in the uk that's what you're
doing that's the price you get
shockingly i do not disagree with
richard
actually i know this is crazy isn't it
wonderful it is it's brilliant because
it's very obvious what we're seeing at
the moment it looks like the beginning
of a plan from liz trust which is an
energy price cap but it's not an energy
price cap because a cap implies that you
are um you know capping the price at
which producers can sell and that
involves them taking a hit potentially
with a small subsidy from the state what
she's really doing is saying you guys
keep all the profits you carry on making
all the extraordinary profits you're
making and we will um
basically pay you the difference between
what consumers are paying at this cap
level so it's corporate welfare
basically but the point is this isn't
for six months peers we're in a global
energy war that could last three five
seven years so you have to have a plan
that responds to that the problem that's
trust has got is that none of the plans
she has for making britain less energy
dependent on other countries are going
to kick in before an election exactly
she's got a ticking clock to violation i
want to bring in douglas murray across
the pond there in new york douglas
looking from afar what what do you make
of this this trust i don't think i can
ever remember any leader shortly
after world war ii inheriting a worse
situation than this do you have any
confidence that liz trusts is the woman
to guide us to
to quieter waters to calmer waters
not very much i wish her well as i think
everybody
should uh the only person i can think of
who came into a worse position was
theresa
theresa may after her very bad call in
the 2017 uh general election
the problem that liz truss is getting
into is this as as your other guests
have just said um it's unlikely whatever
she does that the benefits of her
governance are going to be felt fast uh
everything to do with the energy crisis
everything to do with the costs of
living crisis
she's got basically two years uh uh to
solve these things and it seems very
unlikely she could do it in that time
and here's here's the bigger problem
here's as you well know
we're now 12 years in to conservative
governments in the uk 12 years
and to a great extent this feels to me
like the major years when you have that
third press of the conservative talent
and you had all of these crises and the
feeling that they couldn't get on top of
it i of course hope like everybody else
that liz trust can but the problem she
has is that you know the question will
keep being asked particularly by the
labour opposition well who's been
running the joint for the last 12 years
okay for five years the conservative
party had nick clegg manacled to their
leg a very unpleasant situation for
anyone to be in but after those five
years we have had seven years of
conservative
majority rule yeah and you know all of
these all of these questions that are
coming up are questions that could have
been answered before
and you all and i think we are gonna
we're gonna start hearing the same
excuses from conservative ministers as
we've heard in recent years they'll tell
us that the blob is the problem that the
civil service is the problem that the
unions are the problem and all sorts of
other things and they may be right on
that but the question will keep coming
up or who's been in charge i agree i
mean let me bring uh grace back in on
that because the other problem they've
got liz has got she got the specter of
boris johnson and be lurking like this
ugly shadow in the background ready to
pounce you know he did a typical boris
job this morning i was watching it live
he comes out doesn't apologize for
anything no regrets all very buffoonery
these are all my greatest hits it's all
been a tremendous success and see you
later and then the sun came out and kind
of shone on this guy as he sauntered out
of downing street compared to poor old
trust he got poured on and you know he's
a he's a lucky general boris in many
ways doesn't he he then quoted uh some
roman emperor who famously went back to
a farm and plowed the fields what he
didn't mention was that emperor he then
came back from from the field he left
his plan came back to save the country
he sounds like trump when he speaks like
this i know of course i mean you know
why do you think he did this ridiculous
farewell tour uh going around saying
look at all the wonderful things i've
done look at how green i've made britain
despite the fact that if we had actually
gone green we wouldn't be dealing with
the scale of this energy crisis that
we're dealing with right now he's
obviously planning on coming back you
know he's going to go away go on the
speaking circuit make millions make huge
money the book will make millions huge
amounts of money while people in this
country are literally struggling to eat
their homes come back when he's dealt
with all of his offspring and given them
as much i mean richard we are in an era
are we we're shamelessness with
politicians can be very successful
donald trump boris johnson they have no
shame just focus on the track record 12
years as douglas said of tory leadership
tory government has left as you said a
crisis of crisis there are so many you
can't name them all you forget them i
mean this is incompetence it's
negligence and it's the british people
the lowest paid the least well-off yeah
they're going to suffer the most yes and
that's what i really really resent it is
actually the legacy of a failed
macroeconomic agenda that liz trusts is
saying that she's basically going to
revive she's saying i'm the next thing
which by the way her fingerprints have
been all over as a member of successive
governments i've been there ten years
yeah so she's look she's not squeaky
clean coming in here like nothing to do
with me
it was you guv right i mean you know
what's she going to do tax cuts right
okay we've already got high levels
inequality thatcher did we can't afford
to well
it's a big i keep mentioning this
margaret thatcher when she came in and
inherited a very hard situation bad
economy she didn't cut taxes she put she
waited a few years she put them up to
start yeah but the truth the economy
settled down then she shot the rate of
income tax was eighty percent let's be
very clear and then she
you've got to grow your way out of a
crisis after the second world war our
national debt fell from 150 percent uh
down to about 50 percent very very
quickly because of growth and she's
right on that so she's gotta never
growth
actually as leaders from thatcher to
reagan and others have proven when the
economy is doing well and is stable and
you cut taxes you can get the growth but
how do you get the economy out of doing
stable low levels of inequality you need
investment i don't think you
i don't think you can massively increase
borrowing by 100 billion and
cut taxes and expect the government
government balance sheet is absolutely
fine as long as you cut taxes you cut
unnecessary regulations and you go for
growth what you don't do is borrow to
subsidize to give a hundred billion quid
to a bunch of already very rich
investors in operations okay well
talking of bunging millions and millions
of pounds to very rich people we're
gonna come back and talk about me me me
me me megan
and hapless halfway harry uh because
maureen caligan one of our other guests
on the pack today in new york wrote one
of the most extoriating pieces i've ever
read in my life about anybody about
these two i want to talk to her about
that after the break and also about this
extraordinary case of a teacher in
ireland who's been imprisoned in prison
because he refused to use the right
gender about a transgender student we'll
explain all that after the break stay
with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
well lincoln either missed them and
frankly i wish i had blinked halfway
harry and meghan debacle touched down in
germany today after a whistled top door
of the uk which they didn't find time to
meet any of their family who all hate
them because they hate them and they
didn't meet a lot of strangers of course
and megan was supposed to be lecturing
young people about equality which is her
favorite subject from her california
mansion uh but instead she stuck to her
specialist subject the one she currently
really loves which is talking about
herself
i'm so grateful to be in your company
today i was first invited to be a
counselor at one young world i was
probably a lot like each of you how am i
here and there i was i was the girl from
suits and i was
surrounded by
world leaders i was so overwhelmed by
this experience i think i even saved my
little paper place card proof that i was
there i belonged i was so nervous
i doubted myself and i wondered i wonder
if i was good enough to even be there
what i was doing in the world albeit
important and meaningful as far as i saw
it was it deserving one young world
saw in me
just as i see in you my life had changed
rather significantly
and i was now a mom and i would ask what
is this world he would come to adopt
and what can we do what can i do to make
it better i don't know what could you do
to make it better you're just so special
and how did you get to sit at the top
table with all the world leaders megan
oh could it be because he married a
british prince and then dragged him out
of his country to your california
mansion to fleece your royal titles
anyway 54 times you mentioned yourself
in a seven minute speech even i haven't
done that in a speech that gives you
some idea of the scale of the netflix
narcissist um my question really is how
can they be allowed to do this to run
around like a rival royal family
including in this country a country
they've been trashing with a monarchy
they've been trashing with the royal
family they've been trashing
why do we let this happen i want to go
to new york post columnist maureen
keller everybody very patiently maureen
welcome to the show great to have you on
uh you wrote a absolutely thank you for
having me will you write one of the
all-time great tub thumping extoriating
pieces uh about this last week which i
read on holidays
i thought even i couldn't have written
one quite as savage um so
congratulations but uh tell me what is
it because there's been this kind of
mythology that in america they all love
meghan markle and are proud of her for
coming over here and stealing harry and
so on what is the reality
this is a common misconception that uh
the brits have i understand why and i
can promise you it nothing could be
further from the truth even you know
that that that profile uh that i that
columned on
ran in new york magazine and it
attracted
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
comments immediately now that is a
self-selecting group of woke leftist
self-identified social justice warriors
and they were piling on megan as a liar
as an insufferable narcissist as
completely inauthentic as who does she
think she is she married into this
family all she does is trash them she's
a hypocrite she's trying to monetize her
own children off the backs of the royal
family the ailing queen
so um that piece you know it's it's not
the first time i've written about megan
it certainly won't be the last but that
piece really hit a nerve i mean the
problem maureen is as a country the
united states has now sent two women
to our royal family wallace simpson and
meghan markle the first one led to an
abdication and the second one might be
leading to the end of the monarchy
we need better quality american women
well i think you need anything you need
to sharpen your bs detector a bit
because um she
apparently the royals themselves caught
on pretty quickly that she was not
everything she appeared to be well i
caught on pretty quickly unfortunately i
then got removed from the job that i had
at the time for disbelieving her
nonsense to oprah winfrey what's quite
interesting is the more she talks the
more people realize she is fork tongue
uh grace blakely can you defend this
woke warrior is she the epitome of
equality is she is she the standard
bearer you know how i feel about this i
just i just don't care like you know i
find it when people like meghan markle
are held up as as you say the standard
bearers of feminism and you know social
justice ridiculous because she is
obviously so far removed from the
concerns and troubles of the vast
majority of women and this idea that we
have now among you know certain parts of
the liberal by the way not left or
socialist liberal
is that you know we need you know
rich women to like lean in and give
inspirational speeches and kind of show
everyone else how to be but ultimately
it's just the same part of this like
weird cult of celebrity that distracts
people from the real issues that are
affecting their lives and
i mean i'm a republican i don't care i
couldn't agree more richard i thought
she'd left the united kingdom right for
privacy and to get away from the royal
family so she didn't have to go to those
sort of charity events that she went to
last night but now she's back talking
about herself and you're thinking hang
on so are you staging a comeback as you
say is it a rival sort of royal gig what
is going on what is going on honestly
what's going on with harry here i was
told on good authority yesterday that
that charles in particular is
unbelievably hurt by what is going on
with his son and daughter-in-law he
doesn't understand what he's done wrong
he remember he walked her down down the
aisle douglas let me bring you back in
here on this um you know there's lots of
plays going on here aren't they with the
sussex but the one i can't get away from
they keep trashing the very institution
that gave them these titles that make
them their millions
there is the ultimate hypocrisy right
there and it's a running soul
well the royal family is clearly just a
leg up for meghan markle who believes
that her position as a duchess now
allows her to inspire us common folk
with her amazing wisdom unfortunately as
we just saw again from that speech her
wisdom is from the school of hallmark
cards-ism uh it's all um
sort of sub obama pseudo inspiring stuff
about how you can be the person you
meant to be for the being that you could
be and everyone else can be like you oh
it's all totally flannel isn't it
none of it ever makes any sense they say
you mostly see this sort of thing in
hallmark cards philosophy
it's all about you being your true self
and all of this sort of thing
it's it's it i don't think that i mean
i've never heard somebody with more of a
tin ear than meghan markle most people
know the reason she's on the platform is
because she married a prince of course
that's it otherwise she's by the way
i've seen 24 of suits exactly the minor
roles and when she says he goes little
old me from suits and look at me now
with all the world leaders why do you
think he got there honestly princess
pinocchio i think the queen should strip
the titles i think we're just done with
it or we should just get rid of all the
titles and get rid of the monarchy
the greatest thing
is mired in scandal and meghan markle is
you know by far the least of their
problems at the moment i think because
we all know well i certainly wouldn't
equate what they've done with what
andrew did so i agree with you about
that but the damage to the monarchy is
what worries me correct because queen is
in very ill health we know that she's
elderly she's 96 she's not going to be
here for a lot longer we know this what
happens next is hugely important the
monarchy is one of the greatest
foundation assets that this country has
we should be very proud of it and you
know this is catastrophic for the royal
family and they've got to deal with it
they've got to they've got to cauterize
the wound frankly i want to show um
talking of cauterizing wounds i want to
show maurice maureen can we get more in
back for a moment what have you seen
this morning but the uh i just written a
column for the new york post uh both you
me and douglas all right post um i've
just written about kim kardashian's
derriere
which has now been appearing on the
front cover of interview magazine
under the american dream
issue of interview we have to have this
apparently as the emblem of the american
dream kim kardashian's gigantic naked
backside bearing off the magazine stands
as an american do you see this
image as the personification of the
american dream
oh
[Laughter]
you know it's a specific kind of
american dream i think it's a kind of
american dream that you know does share
something in common with meghan markle
when you are devoid of really any talent
or
intellectual contribution to make what
do you do you auto generate your content
what is kim kardashian's content it's
her ever-evolving
uncanny valley kind of physicality this
isn't even new she did this before
she was on the cover of paper magazine
and her her bum was
you know out there and uh greased up and
it was shocking at the time and i think
that what is
probably going to be shocking to kim
kardashian is that these kinds of images
no long they fail to shock any longer
exactly the only shocking thing is she
kept some clothes on yeah i agree i
totally agree i want to just mention i
want to just mention uh another story
before we finish with the pack this
extraordinary story of a school teacher
in ireland who's been imprisoned after
refusing to use the pronouns requested
by a trans student enoch burke was
initially suspended by wilson's hospital
school in dublin saying the request was
a violation of his christian beliefs he
was then issued with an injunction and
told not to attend the school after a
public round with the head teacher but
he continued to show up he's now been
thrown in prison for contempt of court
but will now remain in prison until he
quotes purges his contempt effectively
apologizes or is free by the court
douglas murray we've talked a lot about
free speech on this show you and i
at the heart of this i don't even agree
with half the things this teacher seems
to believe or or think but i i respect
his religious beliefs it's a religious
school by the way
what i can't get my head around is that
somebody who refuses to call a singular
human being by the way they which i have
always found preposterous when there's
one person
because he wouldn't use the right
pronoun he's now in prison
albeit for content but the contempt was
because he refused to back down
on not being required to use this
pronoun what do you make of it yeah of
course it's ludicrous
some people might have missed something
very interesting has happened in ireland
in the last couple of decades after the
church scandals of recent years ireland
has effectively de-christianized faster
than any country i've ever seen
but you know you strip one religion out
of a country it doesn't mean the country
loses all sense of religion ireland also
perhaps faster than any european country
i know has gone straight for the
religion of social justice warriorism
it's extraordinary to see it
the way in which it's vehemently
advocated by politicians of almost every
stripe including former terrorists uh
and they all jump into this they all
jump into the pronouns business uh shin
fame pretend that the armed struggle and
indeed bobby sands died for gay rights i
think bobby sands had been a bit annoyed
if you told him he was doing this for
the gays but anyway um they've rewritten
their own history they've got this
massive religion of social justice and
there and and they're militant about it
they're quite as militant as they were
in the past about catholicism yeah but
okay
the victims yeah they bring in grace i
mean just whatever the debate about
transgender and i don't you know i have
no problem showing full respect for
transgender people have full rights to
equality and fairness this whole thing
with pronouns the idea of a teacher
actually ending up in prison because
ultimately because he wouldn't say
to a transgender student you'll call
they that's not why was it he was
because he's in contempt of course and
that's something for the courts because
he refused to he refused a liberal
institution but he refused to back down
on the principle of using a pronoun
cares if the key the school cares he
wouldn't be imprisoned
you know the idea that ireland's been
like taken captive by social justice
ireland is suffering with crises like
a housing crisis that is one of the
worst a teacher is
entitled to a religious guy it's an
employment matter it's not a criminal
matter where the bloke ends up in jail
for the court to decide like it's you
know if he wants to if the student will
be called why should he what no
okay deal with ireland's house
all right deal with the water crisis
deal with the wages okay don't waste
time
you've got it right you're crazy all
right great ever since the financial
crisis you've got to call me hot that's
my pronoun
like a no
definitely not a protected character
sorry sorry if it appears if you want me
my pronoun
every time i come on the show and you
say grace i'm going to let you talk
about whatever i'm going to let you talk
about the economy you're going to call
me i'll let you not talk about meghan
markle or pronouns are going to let you
talk about you'll call me hostage and
climate change i'll call you whatever
you want right if you don't call me hot
you're going to jail
well that's that's the way this works if
it's okay with you i'm not going to call
you hot absolutely
social justice warrior it's probably
where i belong anyway isn't it like my
pronouns on my twitter profile are
actually hot hotter hottest so just for
the record uh i'm actually not joking
they are my preferred pronouns um grace
thank you good to see you richard thank
you douglas maureen in new york thank
you both very much probably the finest
piers pack we've had so far so thank you
for that transatlantic orgy of
intellectual intelligence much
appreciated coming up next rising crime
violence on the streets
pensioners being murdered young girls
being shot dead in their homes have the
police lost control of broken britain
former scotland detective peter blexley
and pastor lorraine jones who lost her
son to gang violence will be here live
they don't agree by the way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
[Applause]
while our understaffed overworked police
forces across the uk bracing themselves
for a winter of surging crime and civil
unrest a leaked national strategy paper
drawn up this summer shows that police
chiefs are worried about a breakdown in
public order even corruption within
their ranks due to the spiraling cost of
living crisis but with crime levels in
england and wales at a 20-year high and
less than six percent of crimes reported
leading to charges the big question is
have the police lost control of our
streets well joining me now former
scotland detective peter blexley and
pastor lorraine jones who acts as a
liaison between police and families
after our own son dwayne was stabbed to
death welcome to both of you um ryan
great to see you um
every day we seem to wake up now to some
new horror young kids stabbing each
other to death a little girl age nine in
liverpool shot dead in her home as part
of some gang uh
thing going on you have a pensioner and
a mobility scooter killed yeah a person
very near me in kensington there's some
leafy kensington shot dead young person
of twenties uh only two days ago
what is going on here and do you feel
from all your connections with the
police and community are the police
losing control of what is happening on
the streets
piers i've been crying out that
we're in a state of emergency and i
really hope our new prime minister hears
with her heart
the evidence is there have they lost
control the evidence is there what's
going on poor olivia she was only nine
years old in the safety of her mother in
her home
shot dead in the chest
we've had countless incidents if not
fatal there is a lot of violence and
crime on our streets it's a state of
emergency what is the answer what is the
answer yes
there needs to be a shift in leadership
and our prime minister can do that
things have spiraled down and down
and we've given the answers the
deprivation
the social economics that has gone
plummeted down
poor
investment in the local community our
young people so the housing there's so
many streams of have we have we though
lorraine have we gone too soft in the
way we deal
with young offenders and one of the
things is stop and search should that be
brought back aggressively now by the
police should we have more police doing
more stopping and searching find the
kids with the knives on the street
that's the problem piers
the government is relying on the police
to do stop and search stop and search
has been going on for decades before my
son was killed it take it's going to
take more intervention than stop and
search what we have to remember is the
police respond to the problems we need
to prevent these things from happening
and that's not going to happen until we
deal with the root causes of what
communities are facing
everyone i know who's had any experience
of crime recently in this country says
the police don't bother responding fast
enough if at all
petty theft and burglaries and so on
just get completely ignored we're seeing
constant increases in violent crime and
we're seeing a lot of sort of woke
police stories popping up in the papers
of them dancing at carnivals and so on
which creates an impression to the
public that while all this mayhem is
going on they're not taking it seriously
enough what's your view indeed it does
the police service of late has come up
with an expression that says with a
service that can't say no
in other words when there's an emergency
of whatever description it may be mental
health or connected to social care for
example the police go and deal with that
well actually
the time has come now for the police
service to stand up and say to
government no give me three things that
this trust should do
uh take away from the police this this
dreadful amount of mental health work
that they're having to get involved with
same with social care work they're not
mental health workers they're not social
workers carry on with the recruitment
program and entice experienced officers
to come back either in a full-time role
or a supervisory role so that all these
new officers can benefit from good
experience what is morale like amongst
the police rock bottom in many regards
officers as many as they're getting
newbies through the front door
experienced guys and girls are going out
of the back door because they've quite
simply had enough not only because of
the workload because of pay and pension
conditions being butchered um so yes
morale is is dreadful it needs to be
attended to and quite frankly those who
are in charge the desk driving officers
that have got their degrees in the last
25 30 years who have letters after their
name as well as in front of them really
need to focus on serving the public
community engagement is not dancing it's
not prancing it's not face painting and
it's not a colored helmet it is serving
the communities that have become victims
of crime attend every crime speak to
every victim that's when public trust
and confidence you know what's
interesting to me is i can see you
nodding there's a lot of agreement here
there's not enough being done we need to
do more i hope your voices get heard i
hope liz truss is listening to this
conversation because she needs to act
and it's getting out of control thank
you both very much indeed i appreciate
it thank you please
well next tonight victim or political
porn isis bride shamima begum has been
branded bitter and twisted by british
journalists who got closer to her than
anybody else he joins me next plus
somebody who thinks we should show mercy
let it come back to britain what do you
think of that we'll discuss after the
break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well shamima vegan is notorious as the
isis bride banned from returning to
britain began with just 15 when she and
two other east london school girls
traveled to syria to join the terrorists
in 2015 her attempt to come home have
sparked a global furore to some she's a
victim a child exploited by terrorists
to others she's a terrorist herself and
a threat to national security the uk
structure of citizenship in 2019 arguing
her bangladeshi heritage means she's not
stateless in practice now the country
will let her in and begin now age 23 is
stuck in a syrian detention camp where
most british people think she should
stay this week another twist she may be
smuggled into syria by canadian spy with
canada now pledging to investigate is it
time to give begum another hearing
perhaps even mercy well joining me now
is filmmaker and journalist andrew drury
he's met and interviewed shamim began on
numerous occasions i think she's playing
the victim and mars and begg an author
and former guantanamo bay detainee
thinks we should let her back into the
country welcome to both of you uh andrew
drury let me ask you you've met her a
number of times
including just five weeks ago i think
you had contact with her so you've got
to know pretty well i have yeah what is
your belief about the kind of person
we're talking about and the kind of
potential threat she may present to this
country if she did come back she's a
manipulator when i first met her i was
filming a documentary and did on a day
off and at that point she was playing
sorry i'm sorry to britain and my last
meeting she started to become a victim
she believes that she was trafficked she
wasn't trafficked she said she was but
she's told me a whole story so she's now
playing this part as a victim
um funny enough you've got a guy who was
in guantanamo bay she asked me if i
could bring a book out there for her um
go go tanama bay diaries um about
somebody was there in their 14 years
about trial because that's how she's
seeing herself now a victim right
there's no victim mowers and beg here's
my problem with this whole case with
shamimba bag i've followed it for a
number of years i just can't get past
the fact that she spent years there
fathering
mothering a number of kids by a jihadi
father who was fighting with isis
she knew what they were doing she saw
what they were doing
and she just stayed and was in my view a
willing accomplice to this whole isis
phenomenon over there why should we show
her any mercy why should we have any
pity for someone who was so merciless
and pitiless herself
oh pierce i don't think it's a question
of mercy at all i think really it's a
question of the law and a question of
the application of it across the board
so for example there are several people
who were part of isis who've returned to
the uk some are in prison some are out
some are on uh terrorism prevention and
uh investigative measures i.e
akin to house arrest so there's
different there's different ways uh that
that britain knows how to and can and
has dealt with this uh the real issue is
is shamima being targeted
because the nationality was revoked was
it a political statement or was it one
that was based on law and i think it's
uh the former and not the latter
the role of the intelligence services in
all of this also cannot be underplayed
and if if you'll allow me i think you
you may remember you came to belmosh in
2014
uh to visit andy coulson i was in
belmont at the time and i was being
prosecuted for sending a generator to
syria now my case fell apart uh the
police delegate declared me innocent and
i was found not guilty but i was held
with an individual
who um
told me a fascinating story he was a
young man from london
who said that he'd been recruited by mi5
to go and spy for them against isis
um and they'd given him huge amounts of
money to do so
uh mi5 and the police eventually thought
that he's a he's playing uh a double
game he's a he's a double agent so they
arrested him and tried to prosecute him
for terrorism
and his case was the first case in
british legal history to have been
almost entirely heard in secret because
of the role of mi5 in his case it was it
was it was completely bizarre okay
if i can i want to focus more on
something
charges well what is the relevance to
shame because it seems to be in hercules
we all know what she did we all know
what she saw we know in my view she made
her relatives
and she should lie in it
so the relevance to this case pierce is
this is that he was then taken put on a
deportation order in the uk and his
nationality was revoked in the uk and
then he was deported so that uh the
details of his case would never become
come to life right so in the same way in
shamim jimmy begum's case
the role of the intelligence service
it's impossible that the security
services that the police didn't know
that an m that a an agent for csis the
canadian intelligence services was
facilitating the travel of her and other
british individuals
if that is what's happened i mean there
are so many unanswered questions here
what is what is not unanswered andrew
drury is is we know that she willingly
was there with these isis killers as
they were committing utter atrocities
again i keep coming back in my head i
was like i don't know why we should let
her back in this country
first he got on to the agent side of it
she wasn't aware she told me how she got
there she wasn't aware of any agent she
had some cut the syrians guided her over
into turkey she says a girl called
shamina was the girl that arranged it
she wasn't um
she it took her only six months she made
her own decision she wasn't watching
videos or she wasn't had some preacher
told or she you know this was her choice
she decided you think she's still
dangerous yeah she wants to be a
somebody like now she sees herself as a
celebrity she enjoys all you know all
this that she's getting from us the
press the media even she'll be watching
this tonight she'll hear you know should
this interview go she loves what she
wanted she would have gone anyway she
wanted to be somebody being part of isis
she thought she was somebody now she's
in the camp she likes being somebody
again she's not she's not a victim i
don't i don't think she has any right to
come back to this country no moral right
i don't think she has a legal right and
i think that most british public agree
with me about this uh got to leave it
there andrew jury thank you very much
indeed mozambique thank you as always
your insightful contribution i
appreciate it that's it from me what are
you up to keep it unsensitive
good night
[Music]
i'm tommy dunn and this is talk tv the
most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited it
has to be interviewing president trump
in the open office in the white house
particularly the little red button he
had on his desk i have no idea what he
did is he went on one of the more moves
he's gonna launch a nuclear strike on
north korea or open up a shark pit that
i then fall into
turned out he pressed it right at the
end
and then walked a butler with a tray
carrying a dark hood
here's the diet coke
[Music]
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm nadira tudor liz trust
vowed to help britain ride out the storm
in her first speech as prime minister
delivering her address at downing street
she said she can had a bold plan and her
first priorities will be cutting taxes
fixing the nhs and dealing with the
energy crisis the new prime minister who
was officially appointed by the queen
earlier is expected to announce a freeze
on bills in the next few days well trust
has handed out the top jobs in her
cabinet tonight teresa coffey has been
made health secretary and deputy prime
minister kwazii kwa tang is the new
chancellor james cleverley has been
promoted to foreign secretary and
leadership rival zwella braverman will
become home secretary while supporters
of rishi sunak steve barkley dominic
robb and grant shaps have been sacked
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign